The health crisis unleashed by the coronavirus as led to an unprecedented
situation for the first time, multiple offices, factories, cities,
and virtually entire countries have closed
During the first half of 2020, we have faced an unimaginable scenario.
Think about it for a minute. If in December,
someone had told us that during this year,
we would see the collapse of the aviation sector, the collapse of oil prices,
the wide-scale closure of factories,
or the multiple declarations of States of alarm and States of exception
throughout the world. We would have said something like, come on, come on.
Where's the hidden.
Camera.
As has happened so many other times before reality ends up being stranger than
fiction.
Of course we don't yet know the full extent of the economic crisis that may
occur closing the doors of entire countries. Doesn't exactly come cheap,
Right? To prevent things from getting out of hand,
virtually every government in the world is approving plans of all kinds.
If you only consider the approved stimulus in public spending loans and
interventions by central banks,
the bill already amounts to trillions of dollars.
Trillion dollars.
So you're talking about a $6.2 trillion bill.
This is about all of us,
and it is way bigger than any of us.
This is Europe's moment.
We have been conducting purchases under our new endemic
emergency purchase program,
which has an overall envelope of 750 billion
euros.
The European central bank pulls out its bazooka and bricks.
All asset purchase records in a week,
the Senate unanimously approves the largest economic bailout and us history of
$2.2 trillion to deal with the coronavirus LPs European
commission proposes recovery plan of 750 billion euros. El Mundo.
Right at this point is when many economists scientists and politicians and
entrepreneurs have put forward a very particular idea why not take advantage of
all these plans to drive new non-polluting technologies?
Have you heard of green recovery,
Or this has made us ask ourselves a question at visual politics.
Does this really make sense?
Can governments boost economic activity while making a big leap towards a
greener economy? What did this plan end up being profitable
And friends? One important detail?
It doesn't matter if you care more or less about climate change,
or if you consider it more or less dangerous because I'm sure everyone,
absolutely. All of us wants a cleaner world, a greener world,
one in which we are more considerate of other creatures,
and that is much less polluted. And if on the way to achieving this end goal,
we also managed to boost prosperity, the number of jobs and economic growth,
then who on earth is not going to stand for this year.
Age.
In order to achieve this, we have to keep a few things very clear.
The fight against pollution will only be possible if we can make it profitable
and make no mistake.
Having to be economically profitable is a noble goal as well.
It means achieving a better world while allowing people to live better to of
course, the question is, is this actually possible.
A different recovery today?
European union is the institution that is investing the most resources in combat
in class.
The so-called European green patch was introduced in December, 2019,
an action plan that aims to make Europe the first carbon neutral continent by
2050, that is in net terms.
It will not emit carbon dioxide into the atmosphere that eventually European
emissions are lower than the CO2 that is withdrawn naturally from it by plants.
Of course it is not an easy task and it's not cheap.
The European commission itself has estimated the investment needed to achieve
that objective at more than 250 billion euros per year.
Something like the complete GDP of Finland or the Czech Republic.
Okay.
Now, after the coronavirus crisis,
the European commission wants to speed things up on the 27th of May commission,
president Ursula Vonda land presented a fund for economic reconstruction,
totaling 750 billion euros.
That's just over $830 billion.
The commission is today proposing a new recovery instrument called next
generation issue worth 750 billion Euro.
Which had been set aside for the commission's political priorities,
but most important among them, the European green pact,
that is the fight against climate change. In this way,
the European commission joins a strategy known as.
Screen recovery.
And in this video,
we are not going to discuss the conditions plan because it still lacks many
details. And besides, well,
you know what these kinds of plans tend to rely too much on regulations,
public spending and the capacity of bureaucrats.
So beyond how the European plan might work this time here on visual politics,
we will take a close look at a few examples in this whole green recovery
adventure and how it could make sense depending on the approach to use.
Well.
The first thing is to be clear,
very clear about the three key objectives that these kinds of strategies have to
follow. First. They need to improve the efficiency with which we use energy.
Second. They have to be able to drive cleaner ways to produce that energy.
That means not only in the richest countries, but also in developing countries.
And third,
they have to encourage the development of new technologies that allow us to
achieve the challenge of becoming carbon neutral or what was being cost
effective and contributing to the improvement.
Well.
With these ideas, clearly in mind, let's start this journey.
Do you want to see in a concrete way,
how green recovery can contribute to the economic recovery? Well,
let's get stuck.
Little big changes.
The first thing we can do is take a look at our cities.
You see, when we think of carbon dioxide emissions,
we usually imagine huge factories with large chimneys pouring out lots of smoke
morning, afternoon, and night. However,
according to data from the European union and the United nations environment
program,
the building's taken into account the construction maintenance and above all the
energy and electricity they consume they account for almost 40%. Yes,
40% of all carbon dioxide emissions in the.
World.
Surprised well friends,
let's take a look at one of the most iconic buildings on the planet.
The most famous skyscraper in New York city.
[Inaudible].
2009.
The owners of the empire state building decided to carry out a comprehensive
reform to reduce the energy consumption of this old giant,
a reform that was done. And this is important,
not only with the aim of reducing its carbon footprint, but also,
and perhaps above all to reduce electricity and heating.
It turns out.
This reform consisted of things as spectacular as changing the window panes to
special ones with greater installation,
changing the lights of the arcade to led lights,
putting reflective barriers behind the radiators,
assembling a shutter management system and installing motors in the lifts that
allow them to generate energy as they move.
Do you think that sounds trivial well pay attention to these numbers in total,
the work's amounted to an investment of $31 million and have managed to reduce
the emissions of this building by 40%.
But do you know what this means in economic terms? Well,
it works out to a supply saving of more than $4 million each year,
$4 million saving for an investment of just over $30 million.
This represents a return of 14%. And if we also take into account the financing,
then we find that the profitability of the project for the owners and tenants
can easily exceed a return of 20% per year.
I'm sure you don't think that is so trivial now.
Well now do the owners of the empire state build
New York city council has calculated that if this intervention were extended to
the cities, other major buildings,
that would be the equivalent of taking more than 1.3 million vehicles off the
road while saving hundreds and hundreds of millions of dollars.
If you think about it, it makes a lot of sense.
So why continue to waste energy and money? But anyway,
let's go a little bit further for the next example.
We're going to travel to India. One of the poorest countries in the world.
[Inaudible].
Between 2014 and 2018,
the size of the led bulb market in this country multiplied by a hundred in
2014, 5 million led bulbs for sold a year.
And that had jumped to more than 670 million, just four years later. And yes,
just as we were asking about the empire state empire case, a priori,
we may find this change trivial to at least until we start taking a look at the
numbers.
Replacing traditional led light bulbs in India has saved more than 30 terawatt
hours.
The equivalent of all electricity consumption in a country like Denmark for an
entire year.
And that's in a country where 75% of electricity is generated by coal,
which means that simple switch to LEDs has eliminated a lot of CO2 emissions.
And that was in the only benefit led bulbs consume up to 75%,
less than traditional bulbs.
Therefore we're talking about enormous savings for many of India's poorest
families,
families who thanks to the savings have seen their purchasing power growth.
Again, why keep wasting energy and money? Well, friends,
there are just two examples among many best of all.
These kinds of policies could be carried out without having to increase public
spending. How can that be?
For example,
instead of handing out subsidies something many politicians are far too used to
doing,
you can reduce consumption taxes on products with a lower environmental impact
such as electric cars,
or you could also extend financing lines on preferential terms or boost
so-called green bonds,
green bonds are debt securities that companies or institutions issue to carry
out environmentally responsible projects.
One way to boost them would be for example,
to improve the taxation conditions for private investors,
something that is already partially happening in countries like the United
States, that is if you've invested your money in financing green projects,
then you pay less tax on the profits you make.
It makes.
Sense. Doesn't it? This could drive economic recovery,
reduce carbon dioxide emissions and save hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars that are commonly used completely. Unproductively.
This is exactly what green recovery is, but wait a minute,
because it doesn't end here.
New strategies for new teams.
The second goal we need in this entire strategy is to promote cleaner ways of
obtaining pertaining energy. And do you know what?
We have some good news here too.
According to data from the Lazard investment bank over the past decade,
wind energy costs have fallen by 69% and the costs of solar energy,
even more by about 88%. In other words, thanks to technological advancement.
These energy sources are three to eight times cheaper than just 10 years ago.
You may find it surprising, but in many cases,
wind and solar energy are already fully competitive in the market.
Yeah.
In fact, this explains why, for example, a place like Texas, the Mecca,
the epicenter,
the heart of America's oil and gas industry is already the leading us state with
the highest installed wind capacity and assumed to be the second in solar
energy. To give you an idea in the United States alone,
there are already more than 3 million green energy related jobs. Friends.
We're talking about a paradigm shift that along with the closure of dirty coal
mining plants that have caused CO2 emissions to fall,
even though the U S economy has continued to grow in recent years,
I don't know. I'll just call it advancement in this field.
Doesn't stop from the land we move on to the oceans.
Take.
This Iberdrola project, the East Anglia one in the North sea,
the largest initiative of a Spanish company in the history of renewables and one
that will become one of the largest offshore wind farms on the planet.
We are talking about a macro project that's in total will involve an investment
of more than 7.5 billion euros for a capacity of 3,100
MW,
a project that already today and its first phase is generating more than 1,300
jobs and has taken a huge leap in the technological learning curve.
You need to look at the big picture because the problem of carbon dioxide
emissions is a global one,
not just something that happens in developed countries.
That is.
If we really want to achieve a cleaner world,
we have to find solutions for developing countries as well. In this way,
we could take advantage of the crisis to promote the transition from dirty
energies, like coal to cleaner ones.
And I'm not talking about renewable energies, but also for example,
liquified natural gas.
Today.
This gas is cheaper than coal and although it is still a fossil fuel,
it is much cleaner.
Think of coal as producing almost half of all CO2 emissions in the world.
In fact, according to data from the international energy agency,
if we simply replaced coal with other fossil fuels such as natural gas,
our total global emissions would be reduced by almost 25%. I mean,
we could have the same energy but much cheaper.
Cleanup.
To achieve this governments in the most developed countries could promote
private funds that pilot and finance this entire transition.
It would be a good thing for everybody
Along with the benefits of green bonds or financing programs,
the substitution of conventional taxes, such as corporation tax,
or part of VAT for new taxes linked to environmental impact could be considered.
These are taxes that already work with relatively good results in some countries
such as Canada. In other words, make those who pollute pay and reward.
Those who strive.
Multiple loops.
It's complete sense. On one hand,
this change would allow negative externalities to be taxed such as the damage
from pollution. And on the other hand,
it would promote investment in competitive clean technologies and after rules.
That's what we want. Isn't it
There's even more,
all these kinds of changes would also drive research and development of even
newer and more exciting technologies such as hydrogen or capture among many
others.
Something that would ultimately allow us to make a new leap in prosperity
standard of living.
Okay.
This way even governments could participate in venture capital funds led by
private investors. It's something that we talked about a long time ago,
and it's exactly what Israel did to become one of the most innovative countries
in the world and experienced an economic.
Anyway.
As you could see, there are lots of possibilities which indicate green recovery.
Not only makes sense, but could also be quite an opportunity,
an opportunity to face the crisis, become more competitive, reach,
higher levels of prosperity and achieve a greener world with the figures we've
seen. It seems something that's perfectly possible to achieve.
Cool.
It is not clear,
not at all clear that these are the kinds of policies that the politicians who
for example are leading the European union have in mind.
That's why here on this channel,
we wanted to put on the table some alternatives,
which might be good for everyone. But having said that, it's your turn.
What do you think of green recovery?
Do you think our government should move in that direction?
What do you think is the best formula for dealing with this crisis?
Leave your answer in the comments. So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please hit like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Also,
this channel was possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform,
please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next.
Yeah.